[Applause]
prince william and kate middleton know
how to get down on the dance floor it
seems that kate's more willing to let
her guard down a bit and show us a bit
more of the real kate not just the
duchess of cambridge the duke and
duchess of cambridge kicked off their
first full day of official engagements
on their royal tour of the caribbean in
belize on sunday showing off some of
their best moves while visiting with the
garifuna community in hopkins
yep that's william taking 57 year old
local laura cacho for a spin
and laura she loved it telling royal
reporters that the 39 year old prince is
a good dancer adding that he shook his
waist to the music and had beautiful
rhythm
and kate she knows how to shimmy too
she now has a decade of royal experience
under her belt but even back at st
andrews where of course this love story
started she was a very self-assured
young woman she knew where she wanted to
go in life and the woman that she wanted
to be the principles that she had then
are the principles that she stands by
today and she's always had a great sense
of faith in herself
that's the mom of three shaking it
rocking a blue tory birch dress bold
earrings and wedge heels
people respect her they look up to her
they admire her she's very much seen as
a role model and i think we've seen more
of the real kate the person behind the
title the hrh duchess of cambridge then
we that we have done
actually ever there's very much a
feeling that she's really begun to let
her guard down i think there is a new
confidence about her i think that comes
with age she is now 40 she is very
confident poised self-assured woman and
with a great sense of humor a lot of
talent
[Music]
william and kate took their tour off the
dance floor too stepping out for a walk
on the beach and checking out a local
cocoa plantation farm
but the couple's trip which is in honor
of queen elizabeth's platinum jubilee
got off to a rocky start after
kensington palace confirmed it made a
schedule change due to sensitive issues
involving the indian creek community
according to reuters local villagers
claimed they were not consulted about
william and kate's visit to a farm in
the maya village and were upset that the
royal couple was scheduled to land their
helicopter on land that's at the center
of an ownership rights dispute
in a nutshell the village is at odds
with fauna and flora international a
conservation group which lists prince
william as a patron
local residents were snapped on friday
holding signs in protest some of which
called out the royal but despite having
to cancel one of the weekend's previous
engagements due to the protests the duke
and duchess showed no signs of distress
and kept their date with the dance floor
[Music]
you